and Devastation remains in parts of the
Southern United States following those
deadly storms from last week good
evening to you at 11 I'm Brian Loftis
now a local man says his sister was one
of the more than two dozen people killed
in last week's storm he said his entire
family that lives in Mississippi has
lost everything they have now he's doing
what he can to help them Sasha Loftus
live in studio joining us tonight with a
story you'll only see on eight news now
Brian the man I spoke with tonight is
1600 miles away from his hometown in
Mississippi but he says he's still
feeling so much shock and grief for his
family that's been devastated by this
storm
he said we was just hit by a tornado and
everything is gone those are the words
Charles Harris Jr heard when he touched
down in Mississippi last week
who was born and raised in Rolling Fork
was traveling home to see family when an
ef4 tornado destroyed the town and there
was this debris everywhere I mean there
was no buildings his sister Dolores
Harris was one of the 26 killed in the
devastating storm path he says her home
was ripped from the ground with her
inside it you started calling her name
and looking for
and he said he just I'm alone she was
laying on the ground 40 members of his
family his fan also lost everything and
the place he grew up is now reduced to
Rubble I was born and raised there and I
could not recognize the street it was
like I was in a foreign land that's why
Charles says he's doing anything he can
to help them and everyone else in the
town start over it's a helpless feeling
because no one knows where they're going
to be living no one knows where the next
meal after this overwhelming tragedy no
one expected I don't think this time won
I don't think it'll ever be what it was
and it's going to take years
Charles has started a GoFundMe if you'd
like to help a Red Cross volunteer also
left Las Vegas today to help those in
Mississippi dealing with all that
devastation